we're excited about our next guest star
of the mega hit fantasy show the witcher
it's the fourth most watched netflix
show of all time check out these numbers
76 million households worldwide watch
season one henry cavill who we all know
as superman plays gerald the monster
hunter who sword fights his way through
the world of sorcery witches and elves
season two brings new characters plot
twists and of course more monsters
here's a scene where harold here's a
scene where gerald is ambushed by a
menacing tree monster
uh
wow
henry cavill's joining us right now good
morning henry how are you doing i'm very
well thanks all right so season two is
expected to be bigger and better what
can viewers expect
we can expect uh some fantastic
performances especially from freyja and
anya they are they are absolutely
brilliant um anya's got some some
original story um to play with as well
and uh the vfx is extraordinary and the
way the show looks it really has come on
from the last season and um it's it's
it's brilliant our directors of
photography are fantastic you were
telling gayle earlier that you pushed
for season two to more closely align
with the books are the books the reason
you got into it in the first place um
the books actually i thought the books
were a product of the games so i was
playing the games first and then i was
told that i'd seen the books in the
bookstores and i just figured they
worked did the game work on the front
that they were actually based upon the
games i then learned that they were not
and so i read the books and i absolutely
loved them um as a pairing the games and
the books are brilliant together but uh
yeah then i i pushed for
um changes what changes
there's only so much that um i can
change when it comes to a new season um
i can't change plot lines i can't change
story lines right i can't even really
change character trajectory but one
thing i did want to do was
introduce more of the book geralt into
the show and dad is a guy who's more
intellectual he's wiser yeah he's still
grumpy he's still morose and yeah he's
still petulant at times but i really
wanted to make sure we had a
three-dimensional version of the
character rather than a two-dimensional
just grumpy snowman living in the
mountains well he's also he is a very
distinct way of speaking henry he does
how did you decide you wanted him to
speak like that i um i drew inspiration
from doug cockle who uh voiced him for
the games
and i didn't want to do a direct um
impression just of ducks and so i tried
to switch it up a little bit and i was
reading the books
i found out that he was described as
having a metallic voice yeah so that can
come across as pretty much anything yeah
i knew there would be a you're into a
fan base which um would would recognize
me familiar with something similar to
ducks and so but anyway you campaigned
for for this role from the very
beginning i did and then you didn't get
it why did you campaign listen i believe
in putting it out there making it clear
why did you do that because so many
people would be reluctant to campaign
the way you did i i mean i was a huge
fan of the games and i'm i've been doing
this now acting for 21 years and so
whenever i'm doing things like playing
great computer games i'm thinking can i
turn this into a movie can i turn into a
tv show how would i do it and then i
heard that netflix had bought the ip and
so i got my agents chasing them down
like they were kicking the door down so
you're like you're a gamer is what i'm
hearing yeah you're very much a gamer
absolutely uh speaking of being a gamer
you've been an actor for 21 years are
you always one to read comments and
reviews because that's a messy game
a lot of people don't know that a lot of
people don't do that and a lot of
reviews and comments are not very
friendly yeah and and that's okay
i i think it's important for me um i
find it important to read reviews and
read what people have to say what fans
have to say
as long as you take out the the kind of
commentary which is either just blind
loyalty or
um or use destructive or destructive
criticism yeah i mean you suck it may be
fine if but if it's destructive if it's
yeah if it's from a place which is from
a narrative rather than from someone
going look i thought your um your your
turn as geralt sucked that's that's an
opinion that's totally fine mm-hmm um
you can
be able to take that yeah um and the
more you read you might find out why
they thought that and they might have a
point and so then you try and adjust and
you try and grow on that and you have
the people who are who are saying
wonderful positive things as well and
you think okay well i got that bit right
you see which bits are line and which
bits are constant in the negative and
positive um critiques and then you run
with that henry you know ask you to
confirm a rumor that's floating out
there
is it true that you're going to play the
next james bond uh i i wouldn't know um
do you want should we
should we start that rumor i
i would love to have a conversation if
um the conversation were to come my way
as i understand it you would be willing
to uh i'd be willing to have the
conversation i don't know
there's a lot that goes into it it's not
just taking a role it's it's a
conversation about where they're gonna
go with the character what they're gonna
do with the character and
i know uh barbara and mike are very very
talented individuals and so it'd be
wonderful to have a conversation with
them if that were to come my way
i think it's great to have a
conversation i think that's a beautiful
thing would it be wrong to say i think
you'd be a great superman does that
offend you henry
you'd be terrific in part and i think i
want my friends in new jersey to realize
this that you have the original jersey
accent here i mean yeah i mean the
channel island the jersey yeah the
original jersey from the channel islands
um actually the the jersey accent um
comes from a language called
which is a combination of french and
english and uh it does not sound like i
sound mm-hmm but why does he have the
original jersey because the state of new
jersey is named after the former
governor of the channel island where you
were born oh professor
we have to get going
a thing
henry cavill
so much the witcher season 2 comes out
friday